5 25 on your monday morning yet another
freeway interchange makeover on the way
now you should already know about the
centennial bowl you should know about
the big squeeze you might have started
trying to wrap your brain around the
huge changes come at i-15 and trop well
now the nevada department of
transportation has another big project
on the drawing board this is in the
southeast valley sometimes it's called
the henderson spaghetti bowl where the
215 southern beltway meets the 95 515
and i 11. now before crews even lift a
shovel ndot wants to hear from you
there's an in-person public meeting set
for thursday afternoon it's going to be
at the lifeguard arena in downtown
henderson it's also going to be streamed
on indot's facebook page viewers
included in the opportunities to weigh
in now one of ndot's objectives here is
restoring access to gibson from
westbound lake mead that hasn't been a
thing since the last round of changes
there a few years ago the online public
meeting started a week or two ago
scheduled to run through the first week
of july we got all the links for you in
the online version of this story on our
website when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
some driving you crazy email me traffic
8 8 news now dot com